There’s been a strange phenomenon sweeping
central Germany.
While the true extent of its influence is
still unknown, it seems to have been going
on for quite some time now, usually in irregular
intervals.
If you were to head down to any of the towns
within the affected region for a visit, the
chances of you noticing anything out of the
ordinary would still be rather low.
But then again, if you’re in the wrong place
at the wrong time, it's entirely possible
you could witness an occurrence of SCP-3023
- Every arachnophobe's worst nightmare.
One terrifying incident happened at a baseball
game, held during the height of the summer.
With the scorching sun hanging high above
a stadium packed with eager fans, the home
team was neck and neck with their long-time
rivals from the next town over.
As the players took to the field after a changeover,
everything hung in the balance.
The home team’s coach had made a bold change,
sending out a new baseman, a young man named
Jannick Denke.
He was a rookie, untested, but the team’s
strongest veterans had been doing their best
through the whole first half of the game,
and still, the scores were almost tied.
And so, Jannick stepped up to the base, unaware
that making the next catch would change his
life forever.
The crowd was silent, the tension flattening
their cheers and chants to a low murmur as
the rival’s heaviest hitter stepped up to
bat.
He was a behemoth, arms twice the size of
the baseball bat he carried over his broad
shoulder, striding up with confidence as he
readied a swing.
Watching and waiting, a bead of sweat rolled
down Jannick’s forehead, dropping down the
bridge of his nose.
He couldn’t tell which was making him sweat
more: the heat of the sun or his own nerves.
His teammate at the pitcher’s mound lifted
a leg, the baseball in hand.
If he’d gripped the ball any tighter, his
fingernails might’ve splintered and got
lodged in the white synthetic leather wrapped
around it.
Jannick stared, not even bothering to wipe
away the drops of sweat in his eyes.
As his teammate’s throwing arm reeled back
and hurled the ball forward, it felt like
time itself had slowed down.
The rival team’s batter swatted the baseball
out of the air with an earth-shattering CRACK
that sent the ball speeding through the air.
Jannick dashed to catch it; his mitt outstretched.
The ball was careening back down to Earth,
like a white and red meteorite, almost moving
fast enough to burn-up on re-entry as it hurtled
through the atmosphere.
Jannick could feel his heart rattling against
his ribcage as every instinct told him he’d
never make that fateful catch.
In a final act of desperation, he leaped off
the ground with every ounce of strength and…
All around him, the crowd exploded with the
thunderous sounds of overjoyed applause.
The mighty force of the weighty cork ball
was like catching a punch in mid-air, the
tremors of impact rippling down Jannick’s
arm.
He felt that first, before realizing that
the ball was now lodged securely in his hand.
He’d done it, he’d made the catch.
The batter was out.
But before he could even react in celebration…
it happened.
His arm recovered from the initial shock of
the catch just in time to feel the lightning-fast
flurry of small legs scuttling over his skin.
Barely able to catch his breath, the last
thing Jannick saw was something that used
to be a baseball hurriedly crawling up his
chest towards his neck.
From a distance, his teammates, the fans in
the audience only saw him drop to the turf,
flailing his arms trying to brush off something
crawling over him as it attacked and killed
the young baseman in what had otherwise been
the proudest moment of his life.
While that might’ve been the first time
anything like this had ever happened, it certainly
wouldn’t be the last.
Now, have you ever passed by an abandoned
building, and felt an urge to look around
inside?
Of course, a lot of us have, but most of us
are smart enough to resist the urge.
But on the very rare times you and your friends
have worked up the courage to explore somewhere
like this, you’ve probably never found anything
all that interesting.
Then again, you might want to think twice
before sneaking past those ‘Keep Out’
and ‘Condemned’ signs.
Maxi and Iva learned that lesson the hard
way when they gained access to an abandoned
office block.
Maybe they were trying their hand at making
a Blair Witch Project-style amateur found
footage movie.
Or they could’ve been dabbling in some urban
exploration.
Best case, there might’ve been a few pieces
of office furniture left behind by the building’s
previous occupants, something that the removal
company forgot to take when the place was
cleared out.
The pair of them could’ve just helped themselves.
After all, they needed a new folding chair
for their apartment, and there was one just
sitting there…
Trembling through her stifled tears, Iva’s
phone was shuddering in her hand.
The office had been dark, but she was certain
the shadowy shape that had taken Maxi didn’t
belong to a human being.
Clamping her hand over her mouth to silence
her terrified breaths, she peered out from
under the desk, pointing her phone’s camera
wherever she looked as it recorded.
Iva could hear the loud tapping of several
metal legs, moving hurriedly around the empty
office.
The noise would pause at irregular intervals;
every time it stopped, she thought – no,
prayed – that the creature was gone.
But just as Iva went to look, she would hear
that same sound: quick, scampering steps,
the kind of movements that feel unnatural
to look at, that are only possible for things
with eight legs.
Perhaps that made it worse; the creature didn’t
shriek or scream or breathe like you’d expect
of some awful monster in a horror movie.
But then again, how could it?
It had been a chair when Maxi had walked up
to it, nothing more than an ordinary folding
chair.
The patter of metal footsteps stopped again,
this time for longer.
It had to be gone now, she thought.
She gave it another few seconds, just to make
sure the silence wasn’t broken again.
Crawling out from under the desk, her phone
still in hand, Iva allowed herself to breathe
a tentative sigh.
Only for that sigh to become a scream as it
lunged at her, the chair’s seat and back
now the body and maw of an angry arachnid
monster.
As Iva screamed, her phone caught the whole,
gruesome sight on camera.
You might be starting to see a pattern emerging
here.
But there’s yet another twist in this multi-legged
tale.
What if these occurrences weren’t just random
incidents?
Sure, they might fall into the ‘freak of
nature’ category, like so many other anomalous
incidents.
But while it’s unclear exactly how these
particular anomalies come about, could it
be possible that something – or someone
– is creating them on purpose?
Mobile Task Force Alpha-21 were already on
the scene, in the aftermath of the latest
incursion.
The elite Foundation strike team had eliminated
the threat.
Luckily, it had started life as a phone, meaning
they were able to remotely destroy it, causing
its electronic components to detonate.
Not before it had killed two Foundation personnel
though.
Naturally, now came the clean-up operation.
Gathering up evidence, leaving no trace of
what had happened.
The SCP Foundation still had little clue as
to what exactly caused instances of this nature;
a phenomenon they had now designated as SCP-3023.
All they had to go on was a handful of cases,
and footage recovered from a cell phone that
had belonged to an urban explorer who’d
met an untimely end at the jaws of a folding
chair.
But speaking of footage, something unusual
had been caught by a security camera a few
days before the latest SCP-3023 incident.
The security footage showed a man breaking
into an office where the latest 3023 instance
– the telephone – had been found.
As he picked up the phone in question, this
individual’s jaw appeared to unnaturally
split open horizontally, allowing four dark,
tongue-like appendages to emerge.
These appendages rubbed the phone for over
half a minute, before retracting.
The man then returned the phone to its original
place and promptly left the office.
Thanks to further investigations conducted
by the Foundation’s forensic experts, this
unknown individual was identified as a Mr.
Sauer, the owner of a local restaurant.
Naturally, MTF Alpha-21 moved in to apprehend
this suspect, the only real lead as to what
had been causing the multiple instances of
SCP-3023 to begin occurring in Germany.
However, when Sauer was eventually detained,
he showed next to no sign of any anomalies
in his body.
He claimed to have no memory of the events
depicted in the security footage, had never
encountered any previous SCP-3023 instance,
and seemed to possess no knowledge of the
strange properties he'd exhibited on camera.
Nonetheless, the SCP Foundation was forced
to detain Mr. Sauer, although he never displayed
any anomalous behavior ever again.
Now, you might be forgiven for thinking that,
with Sauer held in Foundation custody, everyone
could breathe a sigh of relief.
But, sadly for any arachnophobes watching
at home, new instances of SCP-3023 kept cropping
up, in even stranger and more horrific fashion
than ever before.
Imagine you had a headache, and we’re talking
about a real killer here.
One of those “power drill to the frontal
lobe” migraines.
Maybe you’d spent too much time glued to
a computer screen at work, and all that blue
light from your monitor scrambled your gray
matter.
Or perhaps last night was a pretty wild one,
and after a few too many drinks you were left
feeling hungover the next morning.
What’s your go-to response in that situation?
Obviously, you call in sick to work, then
go to your medicine cabinet or an over-the-counter
pharmacy and grab some basic pain killers.
Paracetamol, aspirin, ibuprofen, all things
that we trust to make us feel better…
not to make things even worse.
To Patrik, this started as one of the most
normal things in the world.
Like you or I, his immediate response to finding
himself suffering from a raging headache was
to grab a gelatine capsule of ibuprofen.
As casually and unsuspectingly as anyone would,
he took the pill in the hopes of quickly relieving
his pain and carrying on with his day, probably
even chasing it down with a quick glass of
water.
Only, unbeknownst and unseen to Patrik, something
happened the moment that ibuprofen capsule
passed through his lips and went towards his
throat.
Something that stopped it from fully going
down his throat, in fact.
Much like the baseball, the folding chair,
the phone – and who knows how many other
unrecorded incidents – the pill had sprouted
eight, spider-like legs.
At first, it started as a gentle cough, like
you’d expect when a capsule gets lodged
in your throat.
Grabbing a tissue, Patrik gave a few grunting
attempts at clearing his airway.
There was definitely something in there, that
almost felt like it was scratching.
Not the kind of scratch at the back of the
throat brought on by some allergies, the kind
of scratching that caused Patrik to cough
up blood when he put a tissue to his mouth.
The kind of scratching that he could feel
moving, crawling around in his windpipe.
Perhaps, if he’d had more time, Patrik could
have raced to the hospital, and had whatever
was clawing its way around his throat removed
safely with that free European healthcare.
Unfortunately, the thing that the capsule
had turned into just as he swallowed it wasn’t
that kind.
Wracked with unimaginable pain, Patrik was
writhing and spluttering uncontrollably, his
mouth filled with more bile and blood than
saliva by that point.
The scratching was moving, and not down through
his esophagus towards his stomach.
It was going outwards, burrowing through the
insides of his neck until it reached his spinal
cord.
By the time the little ibuprofen capsule-sized
instance of SCP-3023 came crawling out from
the back of his neck, Patrik was already dead.
Let’s say you were aware of this, of all
these strange happenings; seemingly ordinary,
everyday objects turning into angry, aggressive
spiders.
Obviously, the Foundation might want to have
a little ‘chat’ with you about how you
came across such information.
But for the sake of argument, imagine you
did know.
You might think the smart idea would be to
leave.
After all, SCP-3023 instances are only known
to occur in a specific region of central Germany,
neatly situated in the middle of Leipzig and
Düsseldorf.
So, you might then think it’s time to up
sticks and leave that area, maybe even leave
Germany altogether.
Just hop in your car and drive to safety.
If only it were that easy.
A family of four was cruising down the autobahn
in an SUV, just another car on the packed
highway.
Exhausted after hours on the road, Matteo
and Nina sat quietly up front, making sure
they didn’t wake their son and daughter,
both asleep in the rear passenger seats.
The car was picking up speed, about to pass
seventy miles per hour as it gradually carried
them home.
Although it wasn’t going to get them all
the way back.
The screech of twisting metal woke both sleeping
kids up screaming, their parents equally shocked
at the sudden noise.
The car lurched and buckled, like something
had collided with it.
But this was no ordinary traffic accident.
Without any rhyme or reason, the front of
their SUV warped itself into the distinctive
shape of a cephalothorax, while the rear turned
into what looked like an abdomen.
As the car shifted and reshaped around them,
the grinding of metal as auto parts became
huge metal legs, Matteo, Nina, and their children
were still trapped inside, never to make it
out.
But the creepy-crawly carnage wasn’t just
contained inside the car.
The newly-born arachnid abomination hurtling
its way down the autobahn managed to maintain
its speed.
Other drivers swerved and slammed on their
brakes to avoid hitting the creature they
couldn’t even believe was scuttling hurriedly
along the highway.
Unfortunately, this led to them careening
into other cars, smashing headfirst into a
pileup that claimed the lives of forty-one
people.
Not that the SCP Foundation would ever admit
it.
With one of their facilities only two hundred
and fifty meters away, they were quick to
dispatch an airstrike to deal with the spidery
SUV once it became clear that Mobile Task
Force Alpha-21 couldn’t contain it.
Across the board, anything capable of sprouting
four pairs of spindly legs and crawling towards
you with the intent to kill tends to rack
up quite the body count.
But dealing with bodies are some people’s
business.
That was the case for Lukas, a newly-qualified
coroner.
After passing years of training, he was working
with the local police department, performing
autopsies and examining bodies to help them
with their investigations.
Sure, it may not have been the most glamorous
profession, but Lukas could sleep soundly
knowing that he’d never get hurt by a dead
body…
A John Doe – a body that hadn’t yet been
identified– had just been brought in, after
police had found him on the side of the road.
Lukas thoroughly washed his hands, put on
his gloves and scrubs, along with the rest
of the autopsy team.
He’d sat in on at least a dozen of these
procedures, studied the relevant process and
techniques, everything had prepared him for
the job of figuring out how someone had died.
But not even the most experienced medical
examiner could be prepared for what happened
next.
Taking the lead, Lukas began by making the
primary incision into the cadaver’s chest.
It always reminded him of a particular scene
in The Thing¸ where a character’s stomach
opened up and became a maw of frightening
teeth, revealing them to be the titular shape-shifting
alien.
That thought was quickly shaken away when
suddenly, to Lukas’ surprise, the body lurched
violently on the examining table.
Not everyone expects dead bodies to be able
to move, and while it might be rare, it’s
also not impossible.
Any number of things can cause someone’s
remains to move after death: muscles atrophying
or spasming, the body filling up with gas
as it breaks down.
Of course, any coroner would expect these
movements to have subsided by the time someone
reaches the autopsy room.
Caught off-guard by the sudden, violent movement,
Lukas stepped away, dropping his scalpel.
His panting breath warmed his face beneath
his surgical mask as he stared for a moment,
waiting to see if the body moved again.
Certain it would be still now, Lukas wrote
the spooky incident off as just a muscle spasm
and leaned over to retrieve his scalpel.
But while he was crouching, he noticed something
strange.
It almost looked as if there were a pair of
protrusions, poking out from under the dead
man’s skin.
Walking around to the other side of the table,
Lukas found two more similar lumps at the
body’s abdomen.
Almost as if something was inside, ready to
force its way out.
Without warning, the John Doe suddenly moved
again on the examining table, only this time
it didn’t stop.
Lukas couldn’t believe his eyes, the man’s
face was still, frozen in the same dead expression,
but his arms and legs were thrashing and writhing
around as if he was somehow still alive.
Four extra limbs suddenly burst from the sides
of the cadaver, and the now eight-legged creature
reared itself up, leaping towards a member
of the autopsy team.
It scuttled and skittered about on its new
appendages, while Lukas watched in horror.
Blood-curdling screams filled the autopsy
room as he bolted for the door.
Lukas raced down the corridor; the coroner
dared not look behind him while sprinting
through the city mortuary.
Behind him, he could hear the thudding of
the spider’s multiple limbs right at his
heels.
Out of the corner of his eyes, right on the
edge of his peripheral vision, he could see
the mass of legs scuttling towards him.
Maybe he would get out, run all the way to
safety before the spider was upon him… but
how can you hope to outrun something with
eight legs, when you only have two?
The most important thing to remember is that
while any unsuspecting inanimate object near
you might suddenly decide to become an angry
spider, the chances of it happening are very,
very low.
But – especially if you happen to be in
central Germany – those chances are never
zero either…
Now go and check out “SCP-2086 MAN EATING
BUS” and “SCP-1562 THE CARNIVOROUS SLIDE”
for more tales of everyday objects that are
far more sinister than they first seem.